[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Карпати,
Косів]
Саме слово «музей» мені не цікаве.
Це мені нагадує «мавзолей».
[сміється]
Тому я називаю «майстерня»,
«ретро-мотомайстерня».
Я не вважаю себе фанатом цієї справи,
але, поки мені це під силу, воно існуватиме.
Є мотоклуб,
поруч ми зробили виставку
ретро-техніки, майстерню,
[Василь Курищук
Президент мотоклубу «Highlanders»]
майстерню і місце для ночівлі водіїв.
Ми самі вирішили це зробити,
без державної підтримки.
Клуб налічує 40 осіб.
Є хлопчик 4-річний,
також маємо 70-річного члена клубу.
Це наша робота.
З «горбатого» Запорожця ми зробили кабріолет.
Робити авто чи мотоцикл —
це все одно, що малювати стару картину.
Не буває так,
щоб кожного дня все виходило.
Буває таке, що тобі не вдається ця робота.
До цього треба ніжніший підхід.
Це майстерня.
Тут усе є: душ, телевізор, інтернет.
Ця майстерня така, що я тут живу і сплю.
Щоб це все функціонувало — цим треба жити.
Найстаріша модель мотоциклу —
копія німецького «DKW».
«DKW RT 125».
Москалі назвали її «Москва».
Якщо ви знаєте, що це «Vespa» —
культовий мотоцикл.
А от москаль, ніби сокирою, обтесав
і назвав «Електрон».
[сміється]
У мене не було цілі,
щоб зібрати усі моделі.
Проте було натхнення і я потроху збирав.
Захопився і понесло —
все життя з мотоциклом.
Тато фронтовик, мати працювала у колгоспі.
У сім'ї нікого не було,
хто б захоплювався мотоциклом.
Не знаю, звідки воно передалося.
Пам'ятаю, у дитинстві
бігав маленький на змагання,
запах диму і мотоциклу
назавжди закарбувалося у пам'яті.
Перший мотоцикл був
подібний до цього.
Не було інтернету
і ти мусив самостійно руками все пізнавати.
Ага, іскра є, все — ти з'їхав вниз,
а нагору доводилося мотор крутити.
Тоді всі мотоцикли працювали
за одним принципом.
Це все дуже просто.
Теперішні мотоцикли трішки
вдосконалені електронікою...
Проте принцип залишився такий самий,
що був у DKW, що у сучасних моделях — однакові.
Ця справа надає мені сил.
Є запал, який мене приваблює.
Так само тримає те, звідки ти родом.
От ніби немає коріння,
бо ти ж ходиш, але воно є.
Колись Франківщина, Косівщина, Коломийщина
проводили чемпіонати Союзу й України.
Була така дисципліна — «багатоденка».
Перегони на витривалість
техніки і людини.
Україна їхала три днів, а Союз — п'ять днів.
Це все відбувалося у горах,
за день проїжджали 400 км.
Зараз ми зробили простіше.
На цій локації вже другий рік поспіль
відбуваються змагання хард ендуро.
Копія румунського світового рівня.
Цього року ми зробили три траси:
профі, аматор і хобі.
Для різного рівня спортсменів.
Узагалі коло мало 30 км,
чотири кола на день.
Гонку назвали «Ruba Grunem».
Ґрунт — це ви знаєте, що земля.
А саме по-народному «грунь» —
це моя земля в горах.
А «руба» — це є заруба.
Усі призи і кубки робили у нас.
Майстри наші — косівські.
Оце косівські майстри роблять,
цього року ми розробляли такі кубки.
Отака наша робота.
Просто воно...
Підтримуємо національного виробника!
[сміється]
Воно, як захопило,
то вже відмовитися неможливо.
По-перше, ти спілкуєшся з природою не через скло,
а наживо.
Крос — це гуркіт, бруд, знайомі,
з якими треба поспілкуватися.
Сідаючи на мотоцикл чи скутер
ти замовкаєш і спілкуєшся з природою.
Живеш тими запахами.
Ти відновлюєшся
і отримуєш заряд енергії.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Олег Сологуб]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Редакторка відео
Карина Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Монтажерка
Марія Теребус]
[Музика
BramaDo]
[Використано фрагменти відео ТРК «НТК»]
[Субтитри
Владислав Цовма]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]